the death toll in the UK continues to
surge with figures just released
confirming that eight hundred and twenty
eight people have died in England alone
in the past 24 hours from coronavirus
nearly 56,000 people have been infected
across the country among them
Prime Minister Boris Johnson who remains
in intensive care
Boris Johnson was given supplementary
oxygen cabinet ministers say he's in a
stable condition and is in good spirits
Rory challenged joins us now live from
London outside the hospital actually
where brass Johnson has been treated
first let's talk about these numbers
Rory 828 that's the death toll just in
England so likely it's going to be a
very bad day for the UK as a whole yeah
if you add up the numbers that have been
individually released by the English
Health Authority by the Welsh Health
Authority Scottish Northern Ireland then
the total that you get for the UK as a
whole at the moment is 936 deaths now
let's just put a massive caveat in there
which is that these figures are likely
to be undercounted but they're also
likely to be slightly over what the UK's
Department of Health puts out later in
the day as the aggregate number for the
whole of the country just because of the
way that all these numbers are counted
up there's always a bit of variation and
it always looks a little bit confusing
they are likely to be under counted
because we know that these are only the
deaths are taking place in hospitals and
even so there are other hospital deaths
that are going to be pushed in through
the numbers eventually over time they're
going to be many more deaths happening
outside of hospitals and care homes etc
but what we know I think from this is
that the trajectory of the UK's epidemic
is still on the upwards upwards incline
it's going up and up and up day by day
with a few variations but yes this is
still a situation that is getting worse
and worse and worse in the UK on the
death side of things on the hospital
admissions and the new cases side of
things well then there's a bit more
optimism
there because that the chief scientists
and the chief medical officers are
saying that they are I think starting to
see some leveling off they've been
saying that for a few days now a
leveling off in the number of new
hospital admissions of new cases and
Rory do we know any more about how Boris
Johnson is doing other than he's in good
spirits well we basically beginning the
same updates for a day and a half now
every time a spokesperson for the prime
minister comes out or a government
minister and talks about his health the
message is pretty much identical he's
stable clinically stable was the most
recent way of putting it that he's been
given oxygen or he's being given oxygen
he hasn't been put on a ventilator he
hasn't got pneumonia and he's in good
spirits that's the that's the script and
what we've been told that is I think new
in the last couple of hours is that he
seems to be responding to treatment now
we don't know what treatment he's
getting other than oxygen so it suggests
he's not get any worse but we're also
not keep being given any indication that
he's leaving intensive care at anytime
soon we have been told that he is not
working and so yeah we knew that that
means that Dominic rabe is acting as
prime minister but prime minister but
here we're getting I think that the
first signs of cracks in this situation
with the decision announced by Dominic
Raab recently to defer the review of the
of the UK's lockdown which was supposed
to be taking place at the beginning of
next week by April 16th latest but in
the last few hours the prime minister
spokesperson said hold a second no this
review is going to be taking place as
scheduled so yes what what mixed
messages coming from the government at
the moment as you might expect with
Boris Johnson being sick in his hospital
bed behind me and someone else
deputizing for him in the moment
here's hoping we get some clarity I
believe there is a briefing due in the
next few hours for now Thank You Rory
challenge live from London